am i an ai program you wrote to
interview people until i get good enough
to interview you
well i'll be impressed if if you were
i'd be impressed by myself if you were i
don't think we're quite up to that yet
but uh maybe you're from the future lex
if you did would you tell me is that is
that a good thing to tell a language
model that's tasked with interviewing
that it is in fact um ai maybe we're in
a kind of meta turing test uh probably
probably it would be a good idea not to
tell you so it doesn't change your
behavior right this is a kind of
heisenberg uncertainty principle
situation if i told you you behave
differently yeah maybe that's what's
happening with us of course this is a
benchmark from the future where they
replay
2022 as a year before ai's were good
enough yet and now we want to see is it
going to pass exactly
if i was such a
program would you be able to tell do you
think so to the touring test question
you've talked about
the benchmark for solving intelligence
what would be the impressive thing you
talked about winning a nobel prize and a
system winning a nobel prize but i still
return to the touring test as a
compelling test the spirit of the
touring test is a compelling test
yeah the turing test of course it's been
unbelievably influential and turing's
one of my all-time heroes but i think if
you look back at the 1950 papers
original paper and read the original
you'll see i don't think he meant it to
be a rigorous formal test i think it was
more like a thought experiment almost a
bit of philosophy he was writing if you
look at the style of the paper and you
can see he didn't specify it very
rigorously so for example he didn't
specify the knowledge that the expert or
judge would have
um not i mean how much time would they
have to investigate this so these
important parameters if you were gonna
make it uh a true sort of formal test
um and you know some by some measures
people claim the turing test passed
several you know a decade ago i remember
someone claiming that with a with a kind
of very bog standard normal uh uh logic
model um because they pretended it was a
it was a kid so the the judges thought
that the machine you know was was a was
a child so um that would be very
different from an expert ai person uh
interrogating a machine and knowing how
it was built and so on so i think um you
know we should probably move away from
that as a formal test and move more
towards uh a general test where we test
the ai capabilities on a range of tasks
and see if it reaches human level or
above performance on maybe thousands
perhaps even millions of tasks
eventually and cover the entire sort of
cognitive space
so i think um for its time it was an
amazing thought experiment and also
1950s obviously it was barely the dawn
of the computer age so of course he only
thought about text and now um we have a
lot more different inputs
so yeah maybe the better thing to test
is the generalizability so across
multiple tasks but i think it's also
possible as as systems like gotto show
that
eventually that might map right back to
language so you might be able to
demonstrate your ability to generalize
across tasks
by then communicating your ability to
generalize across tasks which is kind of
what we do through conversation anyway
when we jump around
ultimately what's in there in that
conversation is not just you moving
around knowledge
it's you moving around like these
entirely different modalities of
understanding that ultimately map to
your ability to
to uh operate successfully in all of
these domains which you can think of as
tasks
yeah i think certainly we as humans use
language as our main generalization
communication tool so i think we end up
thinking in language and expressing our
solutions in language
so it's going to be very powerful
mode in which to
explain you know the system to explain
what it's doing um but i don't think
it's the only
uh uh modality that matters so i think
there's gonna be a lot of you know
there's there's a lot of different ways
to express uh capabilities uh other than
just language
yeah visual
robotics body language
um
yeah action is the interactive aspect of
all that that's all part of it but
what's interesting with gato is that
it's uh it's it's it's sort of pushing
prediction to the maximum in terms of
like you know mapping arbitrary
sequences to other sequences and sort of
just predicting what's going to happen
next so prediction seems to be uh
fundamental to intelligence
and what you're predicting
doesn't so much matter yeah it seems
like you can generalize that quite well
so obviously language models predict the
next word um gato predicts potentially
any uh action or any token uh and it's
just the beginning really it's our most
general agent one could call it so far
but um you know that itself can be
scaled up massively more than we've done
so far obviously we're in the in the
middle of doing that but the big part of
solving agi is creating benchmarks that
help us get closer and closer sort of
uh creating benchmarks that test the
generalizability and it's just still
interesting that this fella alan turing
was one of the first and probably still
one of the only people that was trying
maybe philosophically but was trying to
formulate a benchmark that could be
followed it is
even though it's it's fuzzy it's still
sufficiently rigorous to where you can
run that test and i still think
something like the touring test will at
the end of the day
be the thing that truly
impresses other humans so that you can
have a close friend
who's an ai system
for that friend to be a good friend
they're going to have to be able to
play
starcraft and they're going to have to
do all of these tasks um get you a beer
so the robotics tasks
uh play games with you
use language humor all those kinds of
things but that ultimately can boil down
to language it feels like not in terms
of the ai community but in terms of the
actual impact of general intelligence on
the world it feels like language will be
the place where it truly shines i think
so because it's such an important kind
of input output for us i think you're
right i think the turing test that what
the the kind of the the philosophy
behind it which is the idea of can can a
machine mimic the behaviors of a a human
and then and i would say wider than just
language and text um then you know in
terms of actions and everything else
creativity all these things then um if
it can sort of match or exceed human
cognitive capabilities then i think we
have a you know true intelligence so i
thought from that perspective you're
right i think he did formulate the right
uh kind of uh setup
i just i think there'll be a kind of
humor
in the ai systems the future looking
back to this conversation
and thinking about the touring test
and uh also thinking about
by that time they would know which year
they were finally able to sort of
cross the threshold of human level
intelligence and think how funny it is
that we humans were still
confused about this whole problem
that has been long ago been solved
well hello to the ai agents of the
future
you